calvin lucian stands at the end of a
dusty table in an abandoned warehouse in
the shadows across from him sits several
hidden figures the warehouse is falling
apart but is suitable for the meeting
calvin has requested with the heads of
the chaos insurgency he has completed
numerous missions for the organization
and each one has been successful now he
is proposing one final mission calvin
lucian takes a tattered journal out of
his bag and slides it across the table
to the figure sitting in the shadows
it's a journal with details on the
habits of each of the 13 foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
whispers from across the table as calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they have been meddling with
reality the business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are immortal calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a silence from the shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of calvin a
deep voice from the shadows says
do it calvin lucian gathers his team the
code name given to the group is kill
squad he informs them that they've been
cleared to take out the overseers it
will be the most dangerous mission
they've ever been on and even if
successful they probably won't make it
out alive but the team is loyal they set
out to confront the 13th overseer this
has to be their first stop because
without eliminating 05-13
nothing else will matter it is this
overseer who has a deal with death a
deal that protects all of the foundation
overseers from dying if that deal can be
broken then calvin lucian and his team
will have a shot at eradicating the
other overseers if the deal with death
cannot be broken all is lost the team
boards a ship at the tip of south
america and sails towards the frozen
waters of antarctica the kill squad is
made up of calvin and three others they
sit in the galley preparing for the
mission ahead anthony wright is a
battle-hardened soldier who sits at one
end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is olivia
torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid adam ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
on to the island they know what needs to
be done anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to full the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crest of the wave the hull is impaled on
the rocks surrounding the tower sending
everything flying towards the front of
the boat see that wasn't so bad calvin
says to his team as he bandages a gash
on his hand knowing what lays ahead
calvin orders his team to wait on the
ship while he makes his own deal with
death he enters the dark structure and
is greeted by a corpse the corpse speaks
to him ejecting dust from its lungs with
every word its breath smells like
decaying flesh death has inhabited the
body of dr felix carter the 13th
overseer calvin is prepared though
thanks to the notes in the journal he
possesses without hesitating he takes
out a small bottle of liquid from his
pocket and lunges at the corpse he grabs
it by the neck tilts the head back and
pours liquid down what is left of the
throat of felix carter the corpse
reanimates into the living dr carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the fountain of youth that
calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that dr
carter is now alive calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower dr felix carter's body
disappears from sight the overseer's
deal with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
cocked to the side looking at calvin so
it is you who has broken the overseer's
deal with me calvin lucian calvin takes
a step back why didn't she stop him from
killing felix carter something festers
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die i thought
that perhaps if i had a seat at their
table i could find it make it die but i
couldn't there are things in this world
beyond even my reach calvin lucian with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill squad contacts the insurgency for
an evac and then makes their way to
japan where 05-12 also known as the
accountant has been working out of tokyo
he is so proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards adam and before he can react
throws the kill squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as olivia helps
adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and corners
the kill squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot adam but olivia
tackles adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his assailant's actions
runs away unable to predict exactly what
they are planning to do the accountant
climbs the stairs to a subway station
and boards the last car of the train it
is empty except for one man calvin
lucian the accountant is dumbfounded how
are you here he screams i should have
seen this coming calvin stands up he
uses his thumb to flip a coin into the
air on the way down he grabs it and
smacks it on the back of his opposing
hand calvin smiles the team has been
making their decisions based on the flip
of a coin which introduced randomness
into their actions that even this super
advanced mathematician could not account
for tell me where 05-11 is demands
calvin the accountant pauses then shakes
his head no if he's going to die either
way then why give any information to the
kill squad kelvin flips the coin up in
the air catches it and looks at it the
coin is face up calvin lifts his pistol
and shoots the accountant in the head a
few nights later olivia stands on a
balcony outside of an art exhibit
overlooking the city of seattle anthony
walks up behind her and tells her that
the foundation is defeated but olivia
doesn't understand how we broke the
overseer's deal with death and killed
the accountant there's nothing more to
do we can go back to our normal lives he
tells her olivia is skeptical though
what about the 11th overseer and his
ability to
olivia's eyes suddenly go wide she pulls
out a knife and stabs it into anthony's
heart the world around her begins to
distort and fall apart it was a false
reality created by 05-11 better known as
the liar olivia wakes up next to adam in
a hotel room she sits up in a bed and
rubs her eyes what a weird dream she
thinks then she realizes it wasn't a
dream she shakes adam awake neither of
them have any idea how they ended up
here but they know it must be the doing
of the liar they had planned for this
though with calvin having created a
contingency plan they pull out a laptop
and log login to view the classified
information calvin left for them olivia
begins to type but stops halfway through
her password and looks up from the
screen olivia pulls out the gun that
rests under her pillow and shoots at him
the false reality created by the liar
falls apart around her olivia comes out
of the previous lie and is sitting
across the table from calvin she
immediately draws her pistol and points
it at calvin's head is it really him or
just another one of the liar's games
calvin tries to talk olivia down and she
looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any olivia begins to relax she
tells calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as calvin morphs
into the liar olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an iv
sitting across from her is a former
insurgency agent named sam beal he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she is free to go olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the iv
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent-lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from the hospital room as olivia's in
the hospital calvin and adam walk
through a dense forest they are
searching for 05-10 the journal
indicates that the 10th overseer's
identity within the foundation is the
archivist in the middle of the clearing
are two saplings standing side by side
the void between the sapling shimmers
coven walks through the portal and the
space begins to warp and twist around
him his vision finally comes back into
focus and calvin finds himself in
another world
adam enters the world behind calvin
practically knocking him over as he
enters through the portal
this is the wanderer's library but it
doesn't look anything like they expected
instead of rows of books the library is
filled with computer mainframes humming
with the collected knowledge of how to
contain anomalies a critical backup
as the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight emerald
tint
it is one of the librarians calvin tells
the librarian that they're seeking the
archivist but the librarian tells them
that the archivist is no longer in the
library she has broken her pact with the
serpent and eaten fruit from the
forbidden trees
if they want to see her though the
librarian can take them to her
calvin and adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge
eventually they reach the bottom of the
stairs where there stands a giant set of
brass doors
beyond the door the librarian explains
is the source of all knowledge
before calvin and adam pass through the
doors though calvin turns to the
librarian before we go in i'd like to
make a withdrawal he says the librarian
nods and pulls out a silver tube out of
its robe it hands the tube to adam and
he looks it over in his hands he looks
up to ask what this is but the librarian
has vanished the door then opens and the
two step through
calvin and adam feel as if they walk
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
that they have walked into a lush green
valley with two trees
sitting underneath one of them is a
woman in a white dress she is reading a
book and eating a piece of fruit
are you the archivist calvin asks the
woman nods yes and that's all the
confirmation calvin needs he raises his
pistol and fires but the bullet passes
right through the archivist as if she
wasn't there
do you read the archivis asked calvin
seemingly not phased by his attempts to
shoot her i haven't had much time
recently calvin replied the archivist
explains that she's read every book in
the library the collected knowledge of
the universe is in the books even one on
how to allow bullets to pass through
your body she came here to find the
secret to immortality it's her job to
document everything that happens in the
world and she can't do that if she's
dead
she explains that she figured out that
the fruit that the serpent forbade
everyone to eat wasn't actual fruit but
the knowledge contained in the library
by having read every book she has
consumed the fruit she no longer needs
the serpent because she was the serpent
the archivist falls to the ground and
begins to ride around contorting her
body as it starts to change she begins
to elongate as her limbs seemingly
disappear the next thing calvin and adam
know they are face to face with a giant
snake calvin dodges as the serpent
lunges at him and adam stands in the
doorway firing at the snake with his
pistol but just like with the
archivist's human form the bullets have
no effect the serpent coils around
calvin and begins to choke the life from
him as adam can only watch helpless
calvin cries out with his last breath
the tube adam open the tube
adam takes the tube that was given to
him by the librarian and opens the cap a
long heavy spear slides out that looks
much too large to have ever fit inside
he drops the tube to the ground and
watches in amazement as it starts to
transform turning into what looks like a
large harpoon gun adam knows what to do
and places the giant spear into the gun
and points it at the serpent
you can't kill me
the giant snake says i've eaten from the
tree of life
adam pulls the trigger and the huge
spear flies through the air striking the
serpent in the head adam runs to calvin
and helps him to his feet they turn to
look at the snake but instead of the
menacing creature it's the archivist
once again pinned against the tree she
once sat under the spear sticking out of
her skull as the two stand looking at
the archivist a tall hooded humanoid
figure steps out from behind the tree it
looks similar to the librarian except
its robe is a greenish color and it
wears long black gloves the creature
pulls the spear out of the archivist
whose body slumps to the ground and
hands the spear to calvin
who are you calvin asks but his question
is ignored
after a moment the figure finally speaks
that spear you'll now hold is called the
spear of the non-believer it is an
ancient weapon used to kill gods it is
odd that someone in this realm gave you
the spear
even with it i'm not sure you will be
able to complete your quest calvin
lucian but we shall see
there is a sudden flash of light and
calvin and adam find themselves
transported back to the forest they had
entered the wanderers library from
a week later calvin and anthony track
down 05-9 who in the council is known as
the outsider she isn't hard to find and
it seems as if she actually wanted to be
found they find her sitting outside of
her burnt down family home the journal
had listed this as her address but
calvin doubted that she would be here
and most he hoped to find a clue to her
whereabouts but here she was
sitting in the ashes of her home without
turning around the outsider began
speaking the council just used me you
know she says they took away my academic
career my friends and my life they made
me conduct research for them that
compromised everything i stood for and
now here i am with nothing the outsider
lets out a sigh she asks calvin if he's
afraid of death calvin shakes his head
and responds now the outsider slumps
forward and kelvin walks around to face
her she is covered in blood her eyes
move to look up at calvin here lying she
says as she dies from self-inflicted
wounds calvin and anthony cross 05-9 off
the list and head back to the car as
they walk anthony says what's been on
everyone's minds the last few days the
easy part is done we'll only get harder
from here we know 05-8 is in his castle
i'm sure we'll get in but i'm not sure
if we'll make it out alive i know
replies calvin but if we're going to
save the world we must eliminate the
rest of the overseers even if it means
sacrificing our own lives they get in
the car and drive off into the blood red
sunset to pick up the rest of the kill
squad team before their next mission
[Music]